after years of rumors will soon be
getting a follow up to one of the
greatest shows in TV history
El Camino a Breaking Bad movie will
debut on Netflix on October 11th and we
have a few ideas of what we'd like to
see when it does first things first the
F El Camino is going to truly satisfy
fans of Breaking Bad it has to feel like
an extension of the series the easiest
way to do this would be through the use
of callbacks Breaking Bad lay down the
callbacks to previous episodes early and
often
a practice which continued in the
spin-off series better call Saul the
callbacks in Breaking Bad were wildly
varied from dialogue to clothing choices
to music and were used for a lot more
than just fanservice I knew this was
going to happen I knew it I told you
that someday someone was gonna come to
our door I am the one who knocks El
Camino will only have a couple of hours
to tell its story and we don't expect it
to spend its entire runtime reminding us
that holy cow we're watching more
Breaking Bad what deploying clever
subtle callbacks to the series is one
way in which El Camino can honor the
show's legacy we get the feeling that El
Camino won't feature too many returning
characters from Breaking Bad or the
simple fact that the majority of the
most significant supporting players are
well dead but thanks to better call Saul
we know that criminal lawyer Saul
Goodman got safely out of town in the
aftermath of White's downfall and ended
up exactly where he predicted he would
manage in a Cinnabon in some nondescript
Mall in Omaha each season of better call
Saul opens with a flash-forward to
Goodman's Cinnabon days and while it's
safe to say he won't be getting sucked
into the criminal underworld of Nebraska
anytime soon that doesn't mean that El
Camino couldn't see Jesse Pinkman pay
him a little visit after all
Goodman could always be depended upon to
bail Pinkman and Weitz out of seemingly
impossible situations and just because
he's lying low slinging cinnamon rolls
doesn't mean he severed all of his ties
to his former criminal associates if
someone's going to fill in Jesse Pinkman
on what's been going down at Albuquerque
since he splits we'd bet it'll be his
old buddies Badger and skinny Pete we
already know that at the very least
skinny Pete will be involved in El
Camino the first trailer to be released
for the flick is simply a scene of the
former drug runner being questioned by
authorities no way
I'm helping you people put Jesse Pinkman
back inside a cage it's not yet clear a
badger will also pop up but where one of
these two goes the other usually follows
and the pair could serve a purpose
beyond merely doling out exposition
there pinkman's connection to
Albuquerque where his parents still live
as does brach the young son of pinkman's
murdered girlfriend Andrea and perhaps
the one living person he cares about the
most badger and skinny Pete might also
warn Pinkman of impending danger wife
may have wiped out the entirety of the
Nazi gang that was holding his former
partner captive in Breaking Bad's final
episode but that doesn't mean said gangs
associates won't be seeking recourse
White's
utter destruction of that Nazi gang by
way of automated machine gun is not the
kind of action that just goes unnoticed
whatever slimy characters that gang was
affiliated with are sure to have taken
notice of two things first there's a
void in the meth production game that
will need to be built second the two
best meth cooks in New Mexico were
present at the scene of that carnage and
one of them is dead but the other is
most certainly not which is to say it
may not just be the long arm of the law
that will take an interest in Pinkman
and El Camino Breaking Bad gave us a
long harrowing look at how drug empires
operates and Pinkman has seen it all
he's been at the center of drug
operations from two coasts mini-empire
to madrigals international drugs
Clearing House and as the New Mexico
narcotics trade rebuilds itself in the
wake of Heisenberg and the Nazis demise
there are sure to be several parties
interested in his whereabouts
whatever road lies ahead for Pinkman it
won't be an easy one but we have to hope
that it brings some kind of closure some
kind of peace because if anyone on earth
ever needed it it's him sure he's done
terrible things but perhaps none of
those things would have come to pass if
he had never been singled out as the
ideal partner by his former teacher mr.
white and despite all of the admittedly
terrible choices he's made Aaron Paul's
incredible soulful performance at a way
of painting Pinkman as someone who
always wanted to do the right thing but
for whatever reason always failed I'm
not coming back I know maybe he'll be
given a chance to rectify the
transgressions of his past in El Camino
this should at least be easier now that
White's who always seemed to be pushing
Pinkman to be the worst possible version
of himself is out of the picture then
again if you're going to cook up a
Breaking Bad movie is be missing a key
and
if it didn't acknowledge Jesse's
departed partner he is the danger he's
the one who knocks Walter White's is the
black infected heart beating at the
center of breaking bat and however it
has to happen it sure seems like failing
to include him in some capacity would be
doing El Camino a disservice it could be
a flashback or a drug-induced vision it
could be a recording that Walter made
for Pinkman in the event of his death or
even a home movie that we see Skyler
white watching right before she throws
it in the fireplace there are a hundred
different ways that could happen but the
subtitle of El Camino is a Breaking Bad
movie and if you're going to offer as a
continuation of one of the greatest
stories ever told on TV you would be
remiss not to offer us at least a
glimpse of that story's greatest
character say my name God right
yes El Camino is Pinkman story but the
character's greatest tragedy is that his
story will forever no matter how much he
would will it to be otherwise be
intertwined with whites make no mistake
there are plenty of fans who had
advanced the theory that white didn't
really die at the conclusion of Breaking
Bad
but we're not among them he is indeed
dead but the dark legacy that he created
will linger as far as Pinkman is
concerned we can only hope that he's
able to run far enough fast enough
to somehow escape it check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]